THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
♪ ♪
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I AM BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPOND TO CALLS
FOR GREATER REGULATION ON
RAPID-FIRE WEAPONRY LIKE THAT
USED IN LAST WEEK'S FLORIDA
SCHOOL SHOOTING AND IN LAS VEGAS
LAST YEAR.
HE IS CALLING ON THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO COME UP WITH NEW
RULES ON SO-CALLED BUMP STOCKS
THAT INCREASE THE SPEED AT WHICH
BULLETS CAN BE FIRED.
BUMP STOCKS WERE USED IN THE
LAS VEGAS SHOOTING, NOT FLORIDA.
BUT THE MOVE COULD EITHER BE A
SIGNAL BY THIS PRESIDENT OF MORE
THINGS TO COME OR A MOVE TO JUST
DO SOMETHING AHEAD OF MEETINGS
THIS WEEK ABOUT THE NEXT STEPS
AFTER A LONG STRING OF MASS
SHOOTINGS.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF FROM
THE NORTH LAWN WITH AN
ANNOUNCEMENT NO ONE REALLY SAW
COMING.
>> IT'S BEEN MORE THAN 140 DAYS
AND WE HAVE HEARD NOTHING FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
HIS BIG EVENT TODAY WHICH WE SAW
OVER YOUR SHOULDER WAS TO HONOR
FIRST RESPONDERS WHO RISKED
THEIR LIVES TO SAVE OTHERS.
THE FLORIDA SHOOTING IN THE
ISSUE OF HOW TO KEEP GUNS OUT OF
THE HANDS OF KILLERS FRONT AND
CENTER.
IN THE WAKE OF THE DOUGLAS
HIGH SCHOOL MASSACRE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP REACHED BACK TO
THE LAST MASS SHOOTING,
LAS VEGAS, ANNOUNCING HE WAS
SICK OF BAN ON SO-CALLED
BUMP STOCKS THAT ALLOW THE
SHOOTER TO FIRE OFF SO MANY
AROUND SO QUICKLY.
>> A FEW MOMENTS AGO I SIGNED A
MEMORANDUM DIRECTING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO PROPOSE
REGULATIONS TO BAN ALL DEVICES
THAT TURN LEGAL WEAPONS INTO
MACHINE GUNS.
I EXPECT THESE CRITICAL
REGULATIONS WILL BE FINALIZED,
JEFF, VERY SOON.
>> HE RECOGNIZED THE VALOR OF
SAFETY OFFICERS WHO RESPONDED TO
YET ANOTHER MASS SHOOTING,
SAN BERNARDINO IN 2015, THE
PRESIDENT PRAISED THE HEROISM OF
THOSE WHO SACRIFICED THEIR LIVES
LAST WEEK.
>> IN THE AFTERMATH OF THIS EVIL
MASSACRE, OR SPIRITS HAVE BEEN
LIFTED BY THE ACCOUNTS OF
BRAVERY AT THE MARJORY STONEMAN
DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL WHO HAVE
SHOWN US THAT THE FORCES OF LOVE
AND COURAGE ARE ALWAYS STRONGER
THAN THE FORCES OF EVIL AND
HATE.
>> DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL IS THE
FIRST MASS SHOOTING IN THE
SCHOOL SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP
TOOK OFFICE.
TODAY HE PLEDGED TO TAKE STEPS
HE SAID WOULD ACTUALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
>> THE KEY IN ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS, AS I SAID IN MY REMARKS
THE DAY AFTER THE SHOOTING, IS
THAT WE CANNOT MERELY TAKE
ACTIONS THAT MAKE US FEEL LIKE
WE ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
WE MUST ACTUALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
>> THE PRESIDENT WILL HOLD
LISTENING SESSIONS THIS WEEK ON
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
TOMORROW HE WILL MEET STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS FROM DOUGLAS
HIGH SCHOOL, SANDY HOOK
ELEMENTARY, AND OTHER SCHOOLS.
THURSDAY HE WILL MEET WITH STATE
AND LOCAL OFFICIALS TO HEAR WHAT
THEY HAVE TO SAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS VOICED
SUPPORT FOR A SENATE BILL THAT
SEEKS TO MAKE A BACKGROUND CHECK
SYSTEM MORE EFFICIENT, BUT WHEN
PRESSED, THE PRESS SECRETARY
INDICATED MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS VERY FOCUSED
ON MENTAL ILLNESS, WORKING WITH
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENT TO DETERMINE THE BEST
PATH FORWARD ON THAT AND WHAT IS
AVAILABLE AND ALLOWED UNDER THE
LAW.
UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN'T JUST FLIP
A SWITCH, BUT THERE IS A
PROCESS.
WE ARE A LAW AND ORDER COUNTRY.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO
DO EVERYTHING HE CAN UNDER HIS
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS AND CERTAINLY WHEN IT
COMES TO MENTAL ILLNESS.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE ALSO DEFENDED
A TWEET PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
WIDELY CRITICIZED FOR.
HE SAID THE WEEKEND MISSED ALL
THE MANY SIGNAL SENT OUT BY THE
FLORIDA SCHOOL SHOOTER BECAUSE
THEY WERE SPENDING TOO MUCH TIME
TRYING TO PROVE RUSH OF
COLLUSION WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> HE WAS MAKING THE POINT THAT
WE WOULD LIKE OUR FBI AGENCIES
TO NOT BE FOCUSED ON SOMETHING
THAT IS CLEARLY A HOAX IN TERMS
OF INVESTIGATING THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND ITS INVOLVEMENT.
>> FOUR DAYS AFTER ROBERT
MUELLER ANNOUNCED INDICTMENTS